a well-designed movie poster
accomplishes many things at once it
shares basic information like the title
cast and release date it also indicates
the film's genre and hints at the plot
but the best posters go one step further
capturing the movies mood and atmosphere
and getting you excited enough to buy a
ticket a poorly designed movie poster
however does only one thing it makes
fans very very angry there may be no
such thing as bad publicity but when
promoting a movie you want to make fans
excited not annoyed the following
posters demonstrate why avatar for the
most part this avatar poster is fine
it's not the most exciting image but it
works at least until you get to the logo
and more specifically the font as far as
typefaces go papyrus isn't quite as
hated as Comic Sans but it's close it's
kitschy boring and constantly used in
inappropriate context graphic designers
hate it the fonts creator Chris Costello
even admitted to CBS News that papyrus
is probably overused to apologize to my
brother and sister of graphic designers
I'm a graphic designer as well in the
years since people haven't forgotten
about this misstep in 2017 eight years
after avatar hit theaters Saturday Night
Live heir to sketch skewering the logo
[Music]
some things are simply unforgivable
papyrus is one of them the heat look at
the British poster for the heat and
without looking at the credits see if
you can figure out who the two stars are
on the Left that's clearly Sandra
Bullock rocking the shades and tactical
vest but who's that skinny
unrecognizable woman on the right
surprise it's none other than Melissa
McCarthy she just looks a little
different thanks to some Photoshop
assisted weight loss naturally
McCarthy's fanbase didn't react well to
the posters implicit body shaming the
actress however handled the controversy
with her trademark sense of humor
jokingly blaming her husband telling The
Hollywood Reporter we had a big fight
about it because I said I wanted it 80%
smaller and he said he wanted it 70%
Star Wars The Force awakens the force
awakens official American poster is
exactly what you'd expect like
via Star Wars posters it features a
painterly collage highlighting most of
the main cast lead characters rey and
finn get a big spotlight while main
villain kylo ren lurks ominously in the
background
han Solo gets a plum spot as he deserves
and some spaceships and stormtroopers
around the whole thing out the Chinese
version is almost exactly the same
except for one key difference instead of
being front and center fin is absolutely
tiny
as far as anyone can tell the only
reason Finn was shrunk is because John
boyega the actor who plays him is black
at least that's what fans argued on
Twitter and they seem to have a point
Poe Dameron and Maz Kanata who are also
both played by actors of color were cut
from the poster entirely
the force awakens might take place a
long time ago in a galaxy far far away
but racism doesn't have any place in the
Star Wars universe x-men apocalypse ask
any x-men fan and they'll agree that
apocalypse is a very bad guy still there
are ways to play up your villains
villainy without resorting to cheap
shock tactics and a heavily criticized
x-men apocalypse poster apocalypses
massive hand is wrapped around
Mystique's neck it's a disturbing choice
for a pg-13 superhero flick and people
noticed the specific violence towards
Jennifer Lawrence's character actress
Rose McGowan led the charge telling The
Hollywood Reporter there is a major
problem when the men and women at 20th
Century Fox think casual violence
against women is the way to market a
film in response to the outcry Fox
quickly apologized and removed the
poster from circulation
spider-man homecoming spider-man
homecomings marketing got off to a great
start first Tom Hollands Peter Parker
made his debut in Captain America Civil
War and almost stole the entire movie
next there were some well-received
teaser posters which let everyone know
that this was the laid-back fun and
fully MCU integrated webslinger we'd
been clamoring to see for years but then
the final poster arrived and to call it
a mess would be kind characters appear
both in and out of costume for no reason
and nothing flows making the final
product look like a rushed Photoshop job
why Sony decided that this muddled busy
image should represent a highly
anticipated spider-man flick remains a
mystery especially considering that some
of the alternate options are pretty darn
good cannot take this anymore guy
gah get out of here mother audiences
either love hate or love to hate Darren
Aronofsky's mother a bizarre
psychological horror drama about a
married couple their unwelcome
houseguests and an emerging cult shortly
after release paramount doubled down on
the film's divisive reception with a
brand new poster the championed mother
as the most controversial movie in
decades naturally that poster was also
controversial and again Jennifer
Lawrence was the victim of violence the
main image split Lawrence's face in two
with one side beaten and battered even
people who liked the movie took issue
with the new poster critic Esther
Zuckerman tweeted I don't care what you
think of the movie the fact that a woman
gets beat up and it shouldn't be the
selling point
paramount representatives have declined
to comment on the posters divided
reaction although they have publicly
stuck up for the film itself
yeah Tomb Raider even if you don't play
video games you probably know Lara Croft
in her infamous assets but in 2013 the
Tomb Raider video game series reboot
toned down Lara's exaggerated physical
attributes and ramped up her ferocious
determination and peerless bow and arrow
skills for the 2018 film adaptation
Alyssia vikander proved to be a strong
fit for this version of the character
this is a lara croft whose cunning smart
and tough while she's certainly not hard
on the eyes there's much more to her
than her looks but you wouldn't know
that from the poster in which some
poorly done photo manipulation
unnaturally elongates McAndrews neck
inviting comparisons to a velociraptor
ultimately this wasn't a problem in the
film itself but in the lead-up to the
release it was hard to think about
anything else
[Music]